point is they wanted to keep him out
because we knew that there was some
black speed and power my friend I feel
like that's extremely racist to say
really to say that black people are
better athletes than white people in
certain Sports I think so yeah really
have you watched an NBA game I'm not
going to say either way is it racist to
say that the majority of the NBA is
black is it racist for me to say that
black people are typically better at
basketball than the average white person
I have no idea I don't know the
statistic bro what are you talking about
man you gave characteristics of black
people which other Coles being faster no
you give different characteristics more
athletic I won't repeat them what
characteristics did I give I can't
repeat them s I'm saying not in the word
itself but the way you stated it is
racis okay so it's not the word it's the
way I stated it that uh in general the
elite black athletes are faster than the
elite white athletes yeah but you
believe that's racist okay so you
believe that's racist that's f